[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to jfg
tonight and we are reconnecting with an
old friend of the show bill gad it's
great to have him how are you doing bill
i'm doing fine jeff i hope you're doing
it just as well
so you had been attracting a lot of
attention on our show back in the days
and i stopped receiving guests for many
years well for a year approximately
because i was annoyed with youtube
censorship and the guests weren't uh up
to
up to date and following the youtube
rules but now i'm on an odd essay and
i've been successful at transferring my
audience here and so it's great we can
have discussions again we can talk with
guests so
today is a day of freedom and as i've
announced before earlier in the week
it's the day of the rope we'll be
talking about the rope hypothesis again
has it been progressing and for those
who have not heard about it
what does it consist of
well um
the rope hypothesis here here it is in a
nutshell
okay
we're saying that uh
we're proposing that all atoms are
interconnected
by a rope-like
entity
a pair of twine threads
think of dna
in fact i think that uh dna copied
the model from the rope okay that's my
take on that because they're all twined
you know
and uh but
i i think we have to take a step even
further down because
uh
what i'm proposing is that
the scientific method itself that we
have today
does not conduce to the answers that we
seek or that the ordinary person seeks
you know you you see a uh a pencil you
know
and you let go of a pencil and it falls
to the floor
and people want to know why did it go to
the floor what caused it to go to the
floor
you know you see uh two magnets
okay those two little round things
they're magnets
and uh you let go one and it sticks to
the other
and so the question is you know people
want to know
what's the mechanism well how does
mother nature do this that those are the
type of questions people want to have
answers to
and
the scientific method that we have today
does not conduce to any of those answers
today we have only irrational
explanations and we've had only
irrational explanations for the last 400
years since the
so-called scientific revolution the 17th
century
all we've had is uh irrational uh
explanations for these things in the
case of gravity they say it's warp space
so we have this canvas that's the way
they illustrate it but they say it's a
four-dimensional concept time and space
that's warped and that's gravity
and i'm not sure with that you can
explain why this pencil falls to the
floor you know it is gravity is uh
space-time warped in this vicinity
and then uh magnets you know they cannot
tell you why one magnet attracts another
from a distance and on and on and on so
the issue is these are the questions
people want answered uh the common man
they don't care about equations they
don't care about you know uh experiments
that people did out there they want to
have answers to these simple questions
and here we are 400 years later after
the so-called scientific revolution and
we don't have answers and i'm saying
that the reason we don't have answers to
those questions
is that
the the scientific method itself is
flawed or or better yet
the scientific method that we're using
today is really a mathematical method it
has to do with mathematics
and the mathematicians what they've done
is they've taken this method and turned
it into the scientific method what is it
about it's about descriptions you
observe something well if you observe
something does that mean you understand
it they talk about the scientific method
being the study of
blah blah blah blah blah
if you study all week it doesn't mean
that you understood you can get a zero
on the test okay so studying itself does
not give you understanding
predictions they say
we can predict yeah with an equation you
can predict many things i can say that
you know if the lion runs i don't know
at 40 kilometers per hour in if he runs
in one straight line in one hour he will
be in such and such place that does not
give us explanations you know the fact
that we can predict things and so
you know the
what i'm saying is that the scientific
method that we have today does not
conduce to the questions that people ask
you know i go into quora where is a site
that answers questions scientific
questions and all other kinds of
questions they're very good in physics
very interesting to see different
perspectives on the questions answered
yeah and so the issue is people go in
there and they ask these types of
questions you know how does a magnet
attract another what does an atom look
like why doesn't the electron fly away
and on and on and on and so
nobody gives them an answer everybody
says you know here's the equation
here's the description
and and it doesn't go beyond that and
i'm saying the first thing we have to do
is attack the scientific method i'm
saying the scientific method has to do
not with what we have today which is a
mathematical method it has to do with
explaining to another human being so
that that person can understand the
mechanism that you propose for a given
phenomenon so if i'm gonna talk about uh
gravity i gotta give you a mechanism not
so that you believe it but that you
understand it
and if i'm going to talk about magnetism
or electricity
i got to show you what i mean by
electricity i got to show you the
mechanism and it's not again not for you
to believe it it's for you to understand
it
and that's what we do with the rope
model i'm saying you know here we have a
rope okay let's see if i can do it this
way yeah farther away
and my uh hands
i don't know i can't get it uh well i'll
do it yeah we see it we totally see it
okay uh here it is okay so we have two
atoms which are my hands right
and we have a rope-like mechanism that
interconnects them
the two threads of the rope are exactly
what make up also the atoms that are at
either end
so not only are the atoms made of the
threads but those threads later on come
out of the atom and twine around go to
another atom which is made of the same
threads then on the other side
we have the same two threats coming out
twined out
to another atom to another atom into
another atom the whole universe is
simply atoms interconnected by
two twenty threads that's as you see the
very simple model and the two twenty
threads uh what are they the blue and
the red
uh yeah in this case blue and red just
to distinguish them but they're it's a
single thread in the entire universe i'm
saying this is the entire universe
okay just a closed loop thread that's it
and this turns into every single
piece of matter that we have out there
and so this is a little different than
what uh mathematical physics proposes
mathematical physics says there are
discrete particles
they're all uh
individual in other words one is
separated from the other they're not
connected in any way
and of course with that model you cannot
explain the force of pull
i cannot pull on you if if everything is
just discrete particles one particle
cannot pull on another part and so i
think that's where it fails that is the
intuitive feeling but
we could be in a universe where pulling
is possible by sending uh sending
particles i mean it's just you just have
to accept the universe as such that you
can pull with gravitons
how do you pull with how do you pull
with particles i i want to see the
mechanism
well i mean and this is what i wanted to
go back to so from the beginning of your
speech there the distinction between
mechanistic and descriptive explanations
intuitively it exists i mean i've been
doing science and i was very interested
in mechanism and very not interested in
descriptions
however is it a fundamental distinction
because in the end if you're like trying
to explain the mechanism behind the car
working
you're going to have the engine you're
going to have a description of the
transmission and you're going to have
all of these parts and how they work but
ultimately what you'll have is a
description of these parts and so is
there a ultimate distinction between
mechanistic and descriptive physics and
if so what is it
well
again i'm saying that we need to have
mechanisms if we're going to talk about
the universe are we saying that the
universe does not function according to
some kind of mechanism like a car
functions according to a mechanism
well uh
the what what i'm saying is that
ultimately any mechanistic explanation
will boil down to a description of the
mechanism right and so
even if you invoke something behind what
you observe let's say i invoke the
transmission behind the working of the
car ultimately the description of the
transmission will be a descriptive
theory it will be a bunch of mathematics
that say when you have something
rotating at this speed with this kind of
gear it results in that much of a
movement of the wheels of the car i will
have a mechanic satisfactorily
mechanistic explanation of the cars
working but that mechanistic explanation
will be a description of the universe
i'm saying uh there's a difference
between a description and an explanation
those two words are not synonyms
explanation is not description if i if
if i
find a box on top of a shelf and i say
how did the box get up there okay i want
to try to explain
how the box got up there so i say well
you know i had a rope and it goes around
the pulley and i tied the box to the
rope pulled on the rope from the other
side the rope went around the pulley and
that's how i got that big box which i
couldn't lift myself that's how i got it
on shelf that's an explanation of a
mechanism that's different than saying
the box got up there that's a
description
yeah but this is in my videos
so in my view mechanisms are meta
descriptions because what you described
is okay a man took the box and went
there that's a description of a man and
presumably the entire description of all
of the atoms making up the man who
brought the box there
would be sufficient to explain why the
box is there
if i say that this magnet attracts that
one
and i just state that that's a
description that's i haven't explained
how even if you were to say there are
little leprechauns in the microscopic
structure of the universe that are
pushing the magnet here and pushing the
magnet there even then you'd be only
describing leprechauns
no because i'm just because you're
focusing on the wrong aspect what i'm
saying what you're saying in that case
is what is the mechanism how did the two
magnets come together and now you're to
go through an explanation of that
mechanism that's different than saying
oh there were two leprechauns you know
that that's a description so far i
haven't explained anything
the explanation has to do with the
mechanism itself that's not a
description again description and
explanation are not synonyms
i think that for a given observable
phenomena its description might be
different from its explanation but what
i'm saying is that ultimately the
explanation is made up of little other
descriptions
yeah but the explanation is the whole
story not the individual steps okay the
whole other explanation is the sum of
how did this happen
what was the i mean we talk about causes
and we talk about uh
you know
what caused the phenomenon to happen you
know what was the mechanism and that's
different than saying
i'm just gonna describe a chair you know
it's blue
you know you can say that as part of
your explanation
but you cannot say that because you say
that this chair is blue you've explained
anything
all right
distinguish between description and
explanation
there are already people asking
questions in super chat as a reminder
you can send super chats and questions
through entropy the link to entropy is
right below the disk the video in the
description and our survey of the night
is what do you think about the rope ipod
is this very good interesting or against
it
we will know if the rope passes tonight
fractalman has sent two super chats is
first is bitcoin to the moon boys uh
bill gate you are so woke on the rope
question
uh are you woke on the crypto currency
question and bitcoin
well i i buy crypto also oh yeah
um i i play the game okay
wonderful because it's been going
extremely well for crypto uh in the last
few months there was a drop recently and
today there is a recovery so you've been
predicting that the financial system
would eventually crumble i guess bitcoin
is the way out naturally
yeah uh
i think it's a modern way of betting not
you don't have to go to vegas anymore
you can do it from home
and with this co-work you know lockdown
i think it's uh perfect for a lot of
people they just stay at home and pull
that you know one arm bandit that's
another thing that people are asking
about is bill gates into the vac stuff
we have learned that the canadian
protest against mandates and vaccination
mandates uh has been enlarging itself
there are no movements in toronto the
city of toronto getting blocked by
tractors today uh there are other cities
where a protest is headed including
quebec
so are you on the side of protesters
there are you four mandates and what do
you think about the vaccine
well for me it's a subject that is
completely irrelevant first of all uh
but uh there's a difference between a
guy like me that i'm this year i'm gonna
be 70
and a guy who's 20 years old there's a
big difference you know in my case i
don't care if they give me a shot
because i'm going to die one way or
another with the vaccine or without it
i i don't have too long to go you know i
don't think i'm going to make it to 100.
but for a guy who's 20 years old who has
to go to work who has to be among other
people
but that guy you know they're scaring
him on one side saying you know if you
don't get the vaccine you're going to
die and on the other the guy said well i
don't believe maybe it's maybe this is
some government hoax or something you
know and so but the guy has you know
supposedly 50 60 more years to live so
he's got a different decision to make
than i do that's the first thing the
other thing is you know i would have
never gotten the backs at all because i
don't need it but i got the vex because
i had to travel first to iceland and
then to south america
and so
and if if you traveled you know the kind
of headaches
that you have if you don't get the backs
that's gonna make life so miserable for
you you might as well get it and again
the distance the difference is between a
guy who's you know 70 or 80 with respect
to a guy who's 20 or 30.
yeah if i was 70 i might get it because
i would be like maybe it's going to save
me a couple of years uh but you you see
through this that you've been extorted
essentially do you experience it as
extortion that for traveling you've been
asked to do something to your body
correct absolutely uh it is an extortion
any way you look at it because when they
compel you
to get a vaccine or you will be locked
down you will be quarantined you'll be
having all kinds of problems uh
my sister-in-law she couldn't get into a
bank in south america because they said
you know you need a vaccine or you need
some kind of or pcr test or whatever and
she couldn't get in there to get her
money out
so you know when you get into situations
like that it's
it's compelling yeah absolutely
fractalman has sent another super chat
he says does the string
fray over time from constant breaking
and what is it composed of
so do the strings break in your theory
uh they're not string we call them
threads first of all but yeah okay
uh second um they don't break
and third they're not made of anything
because
if you go into quantum mechanics or
mathematical physics in general right
they talk about elementary or
fundamental particles what is an
elementary or fundamental particles well
right now it's defined as a particle
that's not made of anything smaller okay
and supposedly the electron is one of
those particles now let's go to the uh
rope model we had we're saying that
everything uh out there is essentially a
single thread that turns into
robes adam's rope so on down the line
okay so everything in the universe is
interconnected because there's if we
could untangle all of it all we would
get is a single thread in the entire
universe
this thread is not made of anything
because
um
again it's an elementary entity meaning
it
by definition it's not made of anything
and if it were made of something that
means that there is space between
whatever
let's say it's made out of two parts
whatever they call we'll call them a and
b
so this thread is made of a and b if
that's the case that means there's space
between a and b because that's the only
way you would be able to distinguish a
from b
and we're saying no it's a single thread
made of a single piece
okay it doesn't stretch therefore
because if it could stretch it would
create new matter
and it's an elementary or fundamental
entity meaning um there's it's it's the
ultimate that's where the buck stops you
know it's not made of anything
smaller that makes it up because
otherwise people say well what is that
other particle made of what is a made
out of well it's made out of x and what
is x made out of and it keeps going and
going
which is what you have in quantum
mechanics
now a couple of things are emerging in
my mind and it's amazing because we've
been talking about this like five or six
shows for hours
and i'm still
and you know there are questions that
are totally new that we've never
explored and they're just popping in my
mind that's a testament to the idea of
bill gate whether you agree with it or
not it's certainly a mind stimulator
so i'm starting to be worried bill gate
i'm starting to be worried about your
nuclei
neutrons and protons
won't they blow up
with all these ropes around them if you
don't have a strong nuclear force do you
have the equivalent of a strong nuclear
force in uh in your model
well uh we don't have a strong nuclear
force because strong nuclear force is
artificial just like quarks are
artificial i mean the strong nuclear
force which are the gluons
in quantum mechanics okay uh
and their job is to keep the quarks
together in other words they they
prevent the course from flying out of
the proton or neutron whichever right
and so the issue here is the following
uh the quarks uh in fact i was
explaining this the other day that
the quarks uh artificially have been
given one-third charge why because if
you have two up quarks with one-third
charge i'm sorry with two thirds charge
each you have four thirds minus one
third uh negative um for the down quark
then you have four thirds minus one
third you have three thirds in other
words one one charge and that's why the
proton has one charge why does the
neutron have zero charge because it's
the other way around you have two
uh down quarks
which are one third each
uh negative and you add two thirds of
one up quad you get zero but oh that's
mathematics so
we don't we've never seen a quark all
that is just mathematics to justify why
the neutron doesn't have charge and the
proton does and the same thing goes with
the gluons they paint them as these
little corkscrews that go from one quart
to another and when you look at that
when you analyze that they say well it's
really a little particle that's
spiraling going from one place to
another okay if that's the case how does
one quark attract another so again this
gluon uh strong force
is just made up just like the quark is
made up just all these particles are
just made up because no one's ever seen
one of these no one's ever photographed
we can't see that far in there and that
small
and and all it is is just a an
accounting procedure to make sure that
you know we get
the proton being one charge and the
neutron being zero charge and i'm saying
well what do you do with the electron i
mean how come the electron has one
charge negative charge you know how do
you do that with these
parts with three parts is the is the
electron also made of uh you know two up
quarks and one down quark
the electron is functioning and you get
the negative charge on the electron the
the electron is fundamental in the model
but uh so are you denying the existence
or the evidence for the existence of
neutrons
no no no absolutely not i'm in my case
uh
we just have a different model of the
neutron we're saying that just like the
proton is the uh
convergence of threads
a neutron is a convergence of ropes
and i have a picture of that you know i
i could show but
i don't have one here yeah okay uh yeah
i'm trying to imagine this so a neutron
would be kind of a
kind of what happens to the atom where
the threads are on them are detaching
themselves and forming single ropes that
are detached but the neutron failed to
do that in some way
failed to do that sorry
yeah what do you mean
because you say it's a convergence of
ropes uh do they arrive at the center of
the atom
yeah
in other words imagine imagine
gazillions of ropes crisscrossing
especially in our region where we have
lots of matter okay
and i'm saying that all these ropes
coming from every atom in the universe
they have to be crisscrossing somewhere
in the universe that the
convergence of ropes
wherever those happen that's what i'm
going to call a neutron and what that
neutron can do it has a free end i'm
going to talk about a free neutron now
one that's not inside an atom if you see
one of these
uh neutron which is a cross point you
know where all these ropes converge and
continue going where they all cross
we're going to call that a neutron that
neutron has the ability for one of the
threads to
uh come out and form part of the
electron shell in which case if the
thread came out all that left be within
the uh enclosure within the membrane all
it left is single
uh threads and that's a pro
proton star covered by a uh
a
electron shell electron membrane and
does there need to be any special event
for a criss-crossing of ropes to lead to
a an observable neutron because it's my
impression that there would be no under
this theory there would be no particular
reason to believe that they would
concentrate at the middle of atoms
i i think uh you would have lots of
atoms in the universe
uh in other words just like you have
many atoms you have gazillions of
neutrons and those are inside the atoms
a lot of them are inside the atoms they
move together with the atom wherever the
atom goes because they're trapped within
the electron shells
remember
so it's the electron shell containing
all these neutrons in a finite space
yeah in other words if you have for
example in the center of one atom and
we'll talk about something higher than
hydrogen because hydrogen doesn't have a
a neutron but you take any other element
and what you're going to have is a
neutron together with a proton inside
the nucleon and that's going to be
covered by an electron shell
and
you can keep going with that and have
more cells depending on you know whether
you have an s1 s2 or a s3 level so you
have all these spheres
that are encapsulating spheres inside
which have neutrons inside
so one inside of that is it it's a it's
a nested system
uh we have another super chat fractalman
says how does your model explain phase
changes have you looked into the
transition between liquid gas solid
that's a question of temperature
in other words uh temperature is a
question of frequency and frequency is
uh in under the rope model it's just a
number of uh links
uh that you have for a given um you know
length of rope and so you could have for
example you know a higher frequency
meaning meaning that the links are
shorter
and in that case you have
heat and you have when you have the
links are longer then you have cold
which is essentially the model we have
today for the uh
spectrum
and uh and the same thing applies to
my model in other words if you have two
atoms and the rope that's connecting
them has many links in other words high
frequency you have heat and when you the
links are longer
then you know you have cold
now it seems to me that if you're if
you're let's say you're intercepting a
rare flight so you have some space
filled with gas or liquid the real
flight comes in
if i hit this thing does it influence
the frequency of the light that's coming
from outside of the place that i'm
eating
well it gets the influence from the
signal from the ropes that are connected
to whatever you're looking at let's say
you're looking at water for example okay
so you have water you say well how does
the water heat well the way it heats is
that you have the ropes that are
connected from the thing that's heating
that water they're all connected to
every molecule inside that pot of water
so every every uh molecule that's inside
the pot is connected to whatever is
heating it whatever you're going to
apply heat to so it's got along each one
of those ropes
it's going to increase the frequency
meaning that the links are going to
become shorter and you're going to have
more links
and that's the high frequency that's
going to stimulate
that atom to vibrate faster until you
know it heats oil but that's a
description of the source of flight
right which would be at a certain
temperature my question is can i heat a
ray of light that passes through me
and change the output for the observer
that's beyond me
in other words can heat influence light
as it's already been sent
already been sent yeah what what the
what the atom can do
what one atom can do if it's excited
it's going to
vibrate and
uh pump at a faster speed the quantum
jump and by doing so it's going to
torque the rope at a faster rate
and it's not that light is going to go
faster it's just that it's going to
change frequency and exchange for uh
for in other words the link length is
going to become shorter
and that stimulus is going to go to
another atom and so on down the line so
at some point you know i mean the rope
is light the whatever goes along the
rope is what we call light and that
signal is going to increase
meaning light is going to travel at the
same speed but what's going to change is
frequency in exchange for wavelength in
the case of our model it's going to be
the
link length is what's going to shorten
and you're going to have more links and
now i'm wondering about one aspect which
is the uni thread of the whole universe
so the whole universe would be a single
thread
one of the properties of a single thread
as opposed to say i could take your
theory and make it a multi-thread theory
what if there was just an infinite
number or close to an infinite number of
threads
essentially linking all atoms but not
being linked one to another in terms of
beginning and beginning end
what is the advantage of having a uni
thread and do you realize that the
feature of a uni thread is that there is
a ultimate order
in the you know in the sense that if i
start from a place of your unique thread
uh i will go through some atoms so there
will be some atoms that i will encounter
before and then some atoms that i will
encounter after there will be an order
effect in describing the universe
well the problem i have with many
threads essentially
is that uh
and i have this in another context but i
think i can kill two birds with one
stone here
um
if if a um an atom for some reason is
not connected to me
i can't see it because the only way i
can see it is through the rope that is
connected from that atom to me
in other words if there's a galaxy out
there and it's not connected for some
reason to me
through these threads because it's uh
it's another
system another thread uh system out
there i would not be able to see it and
that's why i'm saying there could be
parallel universes under my model in
this sense that if there's another
universe next door to us and that whole
thread that makes up all that matter
none of that is connected to our thread
our universe we would not see any of
that universe
okay and so i'm saying that
within the universe what we see
hopefully is um everything that is
connected to us because the only way we
can see is through the rope the torsion
on a rope that is connected to that atom
that we're seeing and the only way i can
picture that maybe there's someone
smarter or making come up with a better
model
within the rope model uh the only way i
can understand that is a single thread
okay but it's counter-intuitive to me
because what you're saying essentially
is that what we see we must be connected
with a rope with the matter that we see
to see it
uh yeah but suppose that i'm at i'm in a
certain spot and there's kind of an
obstacle hiding a star from me
if i move a little bit right i start
seeing the star i move left i don't see
the star anymore are there ropes
disconnecting here or
how do you interpret blockades of flight
i'm saying the rope goes right through
the atoms that are in between your
eyesight and the star in other words you
have a star you have something in
between and you have you okay so you say
you move to the left now you can see it
because it's direct
and you say okay now i move and there's
this other star whatever in front of me
maybe there's a
the moon or whatever it's in front of me
i can't see that star anymore and you're
saying what happens to the road the
ropes are still connected to your eye
from that star and they go right through
the moon or whatever's in front of you
but you don't see it anymore so there's
some intersection there's some
interception of the torque or what
well what you have is uh right now
let's assume it's the moon okay now the
atom of the moon
first of all it's closer second it's
interrupting your your field of view
and you're seeing that atom the other
one the other row goes in the same
direction but all you can do is see that
atom that
comes directly to your eyes
first because it's closer by second it's
got higher intensity okay and then it's
got to do also with the molecular
structure of what you have in front of
you you take a piece of paper and or
maybe let's put a piece of cardboard and
you can't see through it and you take a
piece of glass and you can see through
it you say well what can i see through
the glass why can't i see through
through the cardboard
and that's got to do now with molecular
structure not so not exactly with the uh
with ropes in other words now you've got
to analyze the molecular structure but
this molecular structure of the
cardboard ultimately is such that in
your theory it would absorb rope
stimulus that corresponds to light right
it would absorb it
it will absorb in other words it because
of its molecular structure
uh cardboard has the ability to block
light but black light means it receives
the signal but it doesn't vibrate and
relay the signal to your eye
and then um
i was looking at a beautiful picture i
probably can't find it anymore but but
it was from nasa i believe and it was
the curvature of massive
i i don't know if it was a star or maybe
an entire galaxy somehow a structure out
there in space was curving light so much
so that you were looking at this thing
and you had flashes of light coming at
you on top at the bottom on the side
essentially light was curving and
getting to my eyes you don't believe in
that if i remember correctly but looking
at the picture i was like there's a
pretty convincing case here that some
star behind that star
is sending razor flight through the four
sides some on top some at the bottom and
there's no other way to explain this to
me then light has been curved do you
believe that life or that that light or
that your ropes are getting curved
okay there's a little bit of explaining
to do there the first problem is that
under the
mathematics as i call it mathematical
physics has no explanation for that
phenomena they talk about curved light
or bending light that's not what's
happening even according to mathematical
physics if if light is a little photon a
little particle
then they should talk about deflecting
not about bending there's a difference
between deflecting a ball when you play
baseball or whatever and bending a
banana
okay bending and deflecting are not the
same thing so what these people are
saying that the little ball
curved around what around space time
they say because
uh the star or whatever got in in
between there pushed
space town downwards
created this depression and now the
little photon ball is going to roll
around or slide around that curvature
that's already an irrational explanation
because they're using a concept called
space time they're saying that time is
warped and that's how they get that
explanation through
so that's the first thing we have to
clarify under the rope model it's a
piece of cake very easy very simple
every atom in the universe is connected
to every
atom in the universe we're all connected
okay so now we have the star behind the
sun we have a little star behind the sun
and the sun is essentially eclipsing
that star okay
but that star every atom in that star is
connected to every atom in the sun
meaning it's also connected to every
atom in the corona of the sun
okay the corona is the outer part that
that glow that you know gaseous envelope
that the sun has
every atom in the corona is tied to your
eye
so what happens
you have an atom from the star behind
the sun tied to an atom in the corona in
a straight line because you know it's
tight it's it's like this right
it's a straight line and from that atom
to your eye
now multiply that times gazillions of
atoms and what you have is you've made
that curvature so-called curvature you
did it all with straight lines
it's a little bit i think i've seen you
i think i've seen you invoke this also
in the case of gravity and how we are
attracted to a planet and essentially
the border of the planet are pulling on
the side of the object that's falling
down is that is that a good paradigm
it's not
it's not pulling i want to make sure
that people understand we use the word
pull for gravity and i'm saying it's not
pull we have to understand the mechanism
under the rope model okay and what i'm
saying there is no pull it's not like
gravity is pulling
on an atom
uh for example an astronaut he's full of
atoms right it's not they're pulling on
each atom what happens is as the uh
astronaut drifts
towards the earth
the the ropes that connect each one of
the atoms of his body to every atom on
earth they they open up
see when he's far away they're all in a
single coaxial you could say almost in a
straight line but as he approaches the
earth the the ropes
fan out they they beat you know they uh
keep uh they uh
change their angle with respect to the
astronauts so the angle is changing and
so because there are more independent
ropes acting outside the co the axis
that's what uh that's the acceleration
of gravity which gives us the notion
that oh he's being pulled to the earth
no he's not being pulled he drifts
towards the earth as he falls
the ropes uh fan out and he falls at a
faster rate as more ropes participate
more wrong
when you're closer when you're closer to
the planet more ropes why
because it seems that you're linked to
these there are a lot
imagine imagine if if you have a hundred
ropes and i have a hundred ropes we we
hold them
you hold a hundred and i hold a hundred
if you're at infinity it's a straight
line
but as you come towards me the ropes fan
out ah they open they widen out
that's what's happening it's a matter
kind of almost a resolution concept
where if you look closer to the thing
the fact that the rope is not at the
center because the center is occupied by
some other rope uh makes the the
dimensionality start to matter as you
get closer
yeah what i'm saying as an object
approaches another the every atom in
that object you know the the uh if
they're far apart it's a single it's a
as is it we're a single coaxial but as
they come together they widen out and
now each rope acts independently
but there's no pool it's just that
gravitational attraction is simply a
drift that produces independent ropes
that are outside the axis
so going back to the curvature of the
light uh i imagine three bodies in
perfect alignment
uh the corona of the sun now i can
imagine a rope linking the corona of the
sun to this star extremely far from us
and then i can imagine a straight line
from that corona to my eye
but that to me is a triangle
that is not a curved experience of light
that would make me see the star beside
the corona at best i would see the star
into the corona
what you have to do is uh multiply that
times a million because you're you're
looking at only one rope and you're
saying oh one rope from one atom
to an atom in the corona to an atom in
your eye that's only two ropes and three
atoms
but if you look at the corona the corona
is is you know it's not even a flat disc
it's it's a curvature the corona is
curved around the sun
and you can see
a certain width of that corona so all
those
millions gazillions of atoms there each
one at a different distance one in bc
inside the other or between others you
know when you put all those atoms
together or those ropes together yes you
you should see the whole sun that whole
star in the distance you should see it
you know uh around the corner
so you're telling me there's there's a
there's a there's a uh puzzle that uh
people have that they connect they can
make these curved lines all with
straight lines
you know you make all these straight
lines but you put them you superimpose
them and you create this curve and you
say how do they produce a curve we did
it all with straight lines that's
exactly what i'm proposing
i believe that uh richard feynman adds
something like this maybe but it's it
was about the path pat integrals in
quantum physics but i'm not sure it's
directly related now uh so i want to
understand how are you saying that there
are atoms escaping the sun beyond the
corona and that i would ultimately only
see curvature of light within a space
where atoms have been leaving and are
physically present or are you saying
that the ropes are so packed in at the
corona of the sun that essentially they
have to space out and some of them will
get from totally outside in empty space
and eventually that's where i could see
in other words what i'm asking is the
phenomenon of the the curvature of light
as is interpreted by current physics
would it be observable in perfect vacuum
or does it have to be some matter
escaping from the corona allowing this
kind of visual illusion
are you saying under the rope model or
under your rope model
because you know
once again i clarify mathematical
physics doesn't have an explanation they
you know arthur eddington supposedly
said uh i've answered the question but
he hasn't because
we don't know if that little photon is
rolling around first of all it's not
bent it's it's uh deflected and then the
second thing is being deflected by
curved time
and that's that's nonsense that is
poppycock uh so
that i want to put that one aside but
then under the rope model it's not a
question of atoms leaving the corona i'm
saying that all those atoms are buzzing
around in the corona inside the corona
yeah and they're all there it's not like
one is leaving or anything they're stuck
to the sun because again because of
gravity because each one of those atoms
is connected to the main body of the sun
but you have this uh tenuous gas you
could say you know this region we call
the corona and there are millions and
millions of atoms there one behind
another one next to the other one
between another two and so on there are
millions and millions of atoms in there
and so you know
if each one of those is connected to the
star behind the sun that you know the
sun is eclipsing yeah we should be able
to see that uh star around the corners
only because of the corona the corona is
sending that signal to our eye relaying
i call it relaying it's relaying the
signal that is receiving from that star
uh through the corona to your eye
yeah
it was my impression that we saw a big
distance between
the uh curved light that we observe and
the gravitational objects it seems to me
that it's very far from the corona that
we can observe
these curvature maybe i'm wrong
if i remember the image there was kind
of a space
between the astral entity that's curving
the light and the astral entity that was
observed
well you have to remember there are
atoms uh out there that you know that we
can't really see
in in other words the corona itself has
a gradient and there's a the outer
gradient you you probably won't be able
to see those atoms
you know
now uh thinking about the uh
i'm thinking about the sun now because
we've talked about it for so long uh
free electrons i believe that in the
state of fusion essentially the atoms
are
scrambled and the electrons are not
revolving around the nucleus if i'm
correct how which form does it take in
the rope model diffusion state
the fusion of wood
well fusion like if you're in the sun
how do you model the sun because you
were talking of atoms in the corona but
my understanding is that there are no
atoms in the sun or they they form only
temporarily and they get eventually
bulged refusing into a state where
there's a complete detachment between
electron and proton
well uh
my model is very similar to the official
model in that sense we have a
little bit of the difference and i can
explain that difference to you well
in other words
i i agree totally that the sun
works through fusion in other words you
take four hydrogen atoms you squash them
together and you form a helium atom and
release so-called energy that's the
official model uh the energy that
releases that's according to my rope
model is that it releases
a higher frequency along the ropes and
that's what reaches us higher frequency
that's the so-called energy that's being
released it's thread that's being
released but where we differ is the
following this is where we differ with
mathematical physics mathematical
physics says that because of the
pressures inside the center of the sun
the particles are traveling at great
speeds
that's the official version
i'm saying under the rope model that
doesn't happen under the rope model it's
pressure it's not speed
it's not that see they're used to
accelerating particles in the
accelerators and they think that that's
what's happening inside the sun in fact
they illustrate them like that where
they show that the
particles are moving at great speeds the
hydrogen atoms are moving at great
speeds they're colliding and from four
of those that collide they form a helium
atom i'm saying that's not what's
happening what's happening is because of
gravity because of that constant
pressure on the center all these atoms
are just crowded in a bus and being
squeezed by all the other passengers
so it's they're fused together through
pressure not true speed that's where we
differ other than that my model i agree
with the official model on that
i just have a different interpretation
of what's happening inside the sun
is there a pauli exclusion principle for
ropes can ropes be at the same place at
the same time
well uh
let's let's first clarify that according
to
the quantum mechanics says you apollo
can be at two places at once now you
figure that one out you need two beers
for that one okay at least uh but let's
go the other way around can two
particles be at one place at the same
time according to quantum they can and
according to the rope model they can so
so we don't have a problem there we have
we see eye to eye on that where's the
problem the problem is uh how they fuse
in other words uh according to the
official model uh the one they use they
and then they deny it's the planetary
model of the atom you have a proton in
the center we'll just talk about the
hydrogen because it's the simplest you
have a
ball in the center and you have a little
ball that goes around somewhere
in in a region known as an orbital or a
energy level okay so this little bead is
somewhere in there and what they cannot
explain is why that b doesn't fall to
the proton which is positive oppositely
charged right and why it doesn't fly
away
i mean why does it do either those two
things and so this little bead somehow
magically stays faithful to the proton
under the rope model it's it's a
membrane that is encapsulating a what i
call the proton star it looks like a
star okay or like uh uh you know the
quills of a uh
or uh you know porcupines that's rolled
on itself okay
so all the all the spokes are pointed
outwards and that's encapsulated by
the electron membrane what happens when
two for example two hydrogen atoms come
together they blend they merge and they
form that typical figure eight
molecule which is the h2 molecule okay
so we have an explanation for that we're
saying it's physical and what we're
having is one membrane fuse or male uh
melt into the other one they sort of
screw into each other and they form this
figure eight under the current model the
quantum model they have no explanation
they just say it is so
what's merging the the two uh
energy levels the two orbitals what's
merging if orbitals are regions and
energy levels are regions region is a
concept you can't say love merge with
intelligence what does that mean and
here they have orbitals and energy
levels they merge together they form
that figure eight what merged
so they don't have an answer but but we
we do it with
actual membranes we're saying the
electron is a membrane
and is that the kind of the blue part of
the rope if i remember correctly or red
uh those those are just uh for the
purposes of illustration yeah but i mean
is there
one of the color of the rope is it the
one that forms the electron shell
again just to keep in line with uh
convention we say that one of the
threads goes around and forms the
electron shell we arbitrarily call it
the magnetic thread because we take that
from the magnetic field
and that's again just arbitrary just a
name nothing more than that and the
other one goes through the center and we
call that the electric thread again
because of electric field because i'm
wondering then if it's one of the thread
that becomes the electron shell and
you're talking about the merging of
electron shells do they kind of get a
record of this that would survive
say the explosion of the proton star the
the the order of the universal thread
change at the moment where there is this
kind of merging between
two uh threads that are electron shares
and that become only one
well we need to understand how they
merge what happens is you know imagine
the rope okay
and my my uh fists again two atoms
they're there that's the best i can do
there yeah and what happens as one atom
approaches another one the rope
disintegrates in other words
uh undoes itself
until
uh one of the threads just continues
going into the other
um
the thread that makes the electron shell
of the other atom so what they do they
sort of screw into each other
they screw but they don't it's i was
wondering if it was like if i was to
take
a soldering machine and i was to solder
two parts of your blue rope would that
be would that illustrate the process in
proton stars no no no bad analogy
no i'm saying it's more like it's more
like if you just take a rope do it at
home you know just to visualize what i'm
trying to explain not for you to believe
it but just untie undo it okay so you
have the rope there now you're gonna
undo undo the rope this way okay we're
gonna undo the rope and you can see the
threads are now parallel in that case
right well imagine
two atoms now touching at that point one
is drawn into the other
membrane of the other electro the
uh electron membrane of the other atom
and vice versa and this one's drawn in
this direction so they they sort of
screw at the point where the ropes meet
and then the next rope next to it does
the same then the next one and so they
they're all sort of screwing into each
other the membrane
so it's not it's not welding it's like
undoing of the rope as one atom
approaches another all right bjb says if
time permits please explore bill's time
as a communist spy thank you for your
super chat bjb uh this is something
we've covered on the show back then i
don't think there is much to add uh for
now but we'll get into the uh the
political stuff and the current
geopolitical situation
as soon as we can get resolved with
other questions a lot of people have
been sending questions human drills says
regarding gravity wouldn't want big rope
pulling in one direction
be stronger than many different small
ropes pulling in different directions i
would think the angle decrease would
weaken
the pool
the pull unless the total pull of the
many small ropes would be greater than
the pull of the big rope why would the
small ropes be stronger than their big
rope counterpart
first of all there's no pull
we should get rid of the word pull i use
it too by the way so i'm guilty
because we always talk about
gravitational pull or that gravity is
some kind of pull so we use the word
pull i want to make sure that that's not
the case okay so whenever i use paul
it's uh
don't think of full
okay it's just drifting towards
something and the ropes fan out now if
the ropes fan out uh
they're always under tension in other
words every rope is always under tension
there is no pull along any of the ropes
the rope is always uh made out again uh
you know it's just tight it's pulled
tight but it's there is no rope that
goes loose
exactly
can be and all you have within that is
the speed of light which is different
torsions along each one of those ropes
because one might have an influence of
one
uh entity and another one of another so
one has higher uh frequency and the
other one has lower frequency but all
the ropes
you know light always travels at a
constant speed velocity of light is
little c 300 000 kilometers per second
that's a measure of the tension on the
robe all ropes have the same tension
so it's not like one rope pulls more
than another it's a bigger robe and the
other guy is a smaller rope all ropes
have tension between any two atoms
that's all there is and all we have is
just as one object approaches another
the ropes fan out and the more ropes
that fan out you have acceleration of
gravity
i just realized
as you were speaking i just realized
under your theory arching radiation
doesn't exist
hawking radiation is is funny because uh
they had to
you know the let me tell you what the
story there is real quickly it turns out
that they had nothing to see
you know they they said the astronomers
go look for it what do we look for i
mean a black hole is black you know and
the night sky is black so we won't see
anything they said and so they had to
look for something and so hawking
radiation came around they say oh by the
way space itself is made out of
particles one is positive the other one
is negative the black hole sucks one in
and the other one is left to
to be free to come to your eyes so they
say now now you have something to look
for because there should be some
radiation coming out of black hole
but it's coming out way too slow
it's way too slow and way too weak to be
observable so we won't resolve that one
with experimentation
uh men like gods says mr gate i brought
your name up to alexander unzicker and
he he said he was familiar with you
but not your rope theory perhaps he was
confused regardless i would love to hear
an in-depth discussion with you and mr
unzikr or pm rabbit i are you familiar
with their work thoughts
well uh with unziger we've uh met uh
here in germany we've met he came to my
uh to frankfurt we met we had a morning
breakfast once and we had a lot of talk
about especially uh when they came out
with a picture of the black hole and he
thought it was a lot of baloney and so
we had a long discussion on that a
two-hour breakfast and then we also met
before that in austria in uh salzburg we
had a uh get together there uh what was
it i think 2014 we had two of them in
fact and i think unsugar was in both of
them he was at least in one of them and
yeah we i know his theories quite well
he he's uh he's a
relentless uh
critic of mathematical physics of some
of the claims that people make out there
uh robital i'm not familiar with but uh
i know who he is but i mean i i haven't
heard anything about him
the photo of the black hole has been
quite a a moment that i was highly
anticipating until i saw this donut
uh there's something that remains
mysterious to me which is okay
that that could be a black hole that
absorbs light but there is such a large
ring of flight around the black hole why
is there no ring of light here
obstructing the blackness of the black
hole
uh
like if there is so much matter
converging toward this black hole that
there is basically larger than the black
hole itself there is
uh illuminating fusion matter all around
it why is it not all around it in a 3d
way why can we see the dark spot that's
a question that reminds that that
remains in my mind still what is your
understanding of this picture do you
think it's just an artifact a joke or do
you believe in it
uh the picture i think is real okay but
we gotta know we have to understand what
we're staring at okay and what we're
staring at is according to these people
okay they should have explained it a lot
better we're not looking at a black hole
what we're staring at according to them
is matter falling into a black hole what
we're seeing is uh uh you're a
sink drain you know your drain you put
water in there right and the water falls
into the drain it spires around you can
see the water but you cannot see the
drain so to speak that's essentially the
the case with this picture they're
saying what we're staring at is water
falling into the drain okay
and what what the picture is about the
water falling into the drain it's not
about the black hole per se according to
them because
again the black hole is the singularity
what are you staring at what are you
gonna take what picture you're gonna
think about singularity especially if
it's a mathematical singularity there's
not much to take a picture of so what
they're saying is what you're staring at
is not really a black hole but water
falling or matter falling into the black
hole but what i'm saying is
you can't have that because under
mathematical physics a black hole is
zero dimensional it has no size
you you might say bill you're crazy no
no no let me tell you it has no size not
according to me
uh chandrasekhar
he got the nobel prize you can look this
up don't take my word for it he got the
nobel prize for proving
that a black hole is zero dimensional
has no size no no no uh length width or
height
and you had and you had arthur eddington
who said chandrasekhar you're crazy he
said he's in the 1920s when uh when he
was a chandrasekhar's supervisor and he
said we're not going to allow you to
publish this because what you're saying
is a star can collapse to zero size and
einstein said the same thing he says
you're crazy you're saying that all the
matter gets crushed out of existence and
that's exactly what chandrasekhar got
his nobel prize for don't take my word
for it look it up chandrasekhar proved a
black hole is zero dimensional if it's
zero dimensional what the hell is a
black hole
well the thing is you you could you
acknowledge that
even if the black hole itself would be
zero dimensional uh it represents a
phenomenon of gravity into the universe
such that a much larger space actually
is encompassed by the event horizon
i'm saying that the so-called black hole
phenomena has nothing nothing whatsoever
to do with gravity
it's it's the insistence of
mathematicians who have not found any
other mechanism that they always talk
about mass and gravity i'm saying the
black hole has nothing to do with mass
the black hole has nothing to do with
gravity this is a magnetic phenomenon
it's got to do with the magnetic field
of the galaxy that swishes down all the
threads remember under the rope model
it's a bunch of threads that's what uh
magnetic field is
and you have these physical threads
gazillions of them just sweeping down on
a star and forcing it to roll around in
a in a circle and so they say oh there's
a star moving around in a circle there
must be something very heavy in the
center we'll call that a black hole and
i'm saying it's got not there is nothing
in the center of that orbit what it is
is if you put a charged particle in a
magnetic field it will go around and it
will go around nothing
and that's where the black hole is
are you a secretary jones of the
electric universe guys
[Laughter]
no i wouldn't work for them
no because
they seem extremely uh motivated with
their stuff with seeing magnetism and
electricity as a bigger force than we
typically do
uh yeah so and that they are in line
with you
yeah no but they're not because first of
all uh they use the quantum model of the
atom that's where they they fail and
they're the quantum model is a is the
planetary model that means a little bead
going around and what they say
electricity is is this electron bead
moving from atom to atom and that's
where we have a problem because under
the rope model electricity is not a
little bead that moves from adam to adam
it's a whole bunch of merged
uh electron shells
in a row and they all twirled in situ in
place
so their electricity very different than
my electricity
all right william runner says jf say
hello to bill for me filthy biozo says
is the black hole possibly what we
humans call god i don't think bill gate
is very warm at the idea of god
right
well we got a problem with god good old
god i mean uh he's a nice fellow but he
doesn't exist
poor fellow you know he's he's not
around uh
in order for god to be something he's
got to be
have shape first of all then then we can
say okay god is something because
uh i can paint him i can make a picture
of him i can take a snapshot or whatever
but that's not enough if he wants to
exist if god wants to exist he's got to
have location there's got to be distance
between my chest and his chest
god is everywhere
jesus is everywhere
yeah so uh quantum particles
i wanted to talk a little bit about the
political situation before we conclude
so have you been following this whole uh
russia ukraine it's amazing to see the
american media uh propagandize they've
been actually ridiculed by even emery
some american media are starting to
question the rationality of the biden
administration they started claiming
that putin was preparing some coup was
preparing some kind of fake video where
he would make it look like ukraine
attacked them to charm people on the
internet and there's no evidence for it
it seems that america once war with
russia what's your take on what has been
happening around ukraine
uh i don't think it's the united states
that wants war against uh russia i think
they want to create the
ambient that there is going to be war
and the and this is a chess game you
know it's a chess game and again the
americans have the whites like bobby
fischer usually was a good attacker with
his whites and he had to grant tigran
petrosian which was the russian
counterpart he was the good with the
defenses especially with blacks and so
this is the same this is a good analogy
for what's happening now the americans
cannot fight ukraine uh
uh
this war in ukraine and and say they're
gonna win they don't care about that as
far as i'm concerned they're not
interested in that this war is against
germany this war is against germany
first and france second okay
those are the the targets they want to
stop this pipeline which is uh is
supposed to uh the north stream that is
supposedly going to be approved by june
and they want to stop that they've been
trying that for several months to try to
stop nordstrom the germans said no and
now they're going to use this excuse of
ukraine to say oh look the russians
attacked ukraine and so now stop the
north stream and we're going to
pull germany and france more to our side
because right now germany and france are
more or less independent of the united
states they have treaties not only with
russia but with china and the united
states wants to stop that i think the
united states wants these two
uh countries to be more under their
umbrella and so this war i think is
against germany now what happens
if russia doesn't attack ukraine well no
problem the united states wins no matter
what the united states moves its pawns
it's uh rook it's uh
knight it's a bishop right on the
chessboard and the other guy has to
defend himself if he doesn't defend
himself no problem i'm gonna continue
attacking until at some point he's going
to have to do something and
again i don't think there's going to be
uh the united states is going to go into
ukraine and fight for ukraine first
because there's no treaty uh ukraine
doesn't belong to nato and nato has no
reason to support ukraine other than you
know a pat in the back
this this is an issue where they say i
hope you attack ukraine so that we can
justify to the germans and the french
why they have to be on our side for not
only uh being against russia but also
against china
so this is a war against uh germany this
is the third world war i could call it
and it's always germany that loses
oh wow that that is very interesting
very insightful
but if you're right and i'm putin
then the only error i could make is to
truly attack ukraine
and so the best decision for putin is
to not create escalation to have as many
soldiers as possible to defend the
current border but not go further not
try to acquire anything in ukraine and
make sure that nordstrom 2 goes into
function while not doing any provocation
so as not to give the moral high ground
to america
yeah but again uh bobby fischer would
attack and the other guy had to defend
himself and and he can't just say okay
you do whatever you want i'm just gonna
sit here no he can't sit here uh putin
the russians in general they have to do
something because the united states says
oh you're not doing anything no problem
we're just gonna
move some missiles into ukraine and put
some troops there and it's all for fun
and so the russians at some point will
have to act and that's what the united
states wants to do force the russian
hand
now
there's another take on this that you
might want to consider and that's
what i discussed the other day
i'm saying the following wouldn't it be
nice i mean
russia or better yet the soviet union
uh lost a lot of the countries it was uh
you know over uh in the warsaw pact uh
all these countries are now essentially
on this side on on the you can call it
the blue side
the american side and the only thing
that remains on the other side is uh
belarussa and um and ukraine
more or less
now the ukrainians they speak russian
and uh the eastern uh
provinces essentially have already
fallen to the hands of the russians
ukraine is not a big prize for the
americans again the the prize here is
going to be germany and the united
states wants to provoke this war but
let's assume that the united states wins
in the end and not because it wins a war
but because there's an internal coup
that overthrows putin and his mafia his
group of people okay
if that happens and you get a friendly
government in russia that's friendly
with the west
now that would be nice for the whole
world you know suddenly we have these
two countries which have been enemies
for so long at least for the whole most
of the 20th century right and now these
countries let's assume we're friends and
now there is no enemy between no enmity
between the united states and russia
that would be positive if we could
obtain that and if we had to choose we
would say well it's better for there to
be a coup in russia
have a friendlier government get up
there and we're all friends finally
now i don't know that would be nice it's
a dream but it would be nice
yeah uh that would attract a lot of hate
to america the way iran for example
has been the victim of a coup and has
been after just more hostile to america
uh but then if america is making a war
against germany
why why are they scared of germany they
are scared of the production capacity of
germany
first of all germany is a competitor of
the united states like japan is a
competitor like france is a competitor
it'd be nice if these uh
so-called competitors were neutralized
and uh you know they could better
organize their whole production not only
for
manufacturing but also services etc if
they could organize that or or you know
but they would all be in accord without
competing against each other but they
would work in unison it'd be a lot
better for the united states for the
economy of the united states right now
germany is a competitor you gotta you
gotta stop that
you know germany uh whether we don't
look at it that way is an enemy of the
united states
from a manufacturing uh economic point
of view it's an enemy and then in terms
of disruptions to the supply chain one
of the big problem is taiwan
if taiwan is taken over during all this
time if we're too attentive to this
norton situation and china takes taiwan
we lose a source of chips electronics is
that therefore in the interest of the
america to continue defending taiwan
well that's a tricky situation first
because the united states is already on
record saying that taiwan is part of
china
that's already in the books so it's very
hard to
for let's put it in reverse let's say
california decides to secede from the
union and say well we don't want to be
part of the united states and china
comes in the defense of
california
and sends some weapons there and so on
well you know the americans wouldn't
like that at all and that's a situation
i would love it
i i would rule for china
and the independent republic of
california
no but this is the situation with china
you know taiwan according to uh
official version united nations uh even
uh sports
china's uh taiwan is part of china and
so it's a province of china and it's a
tricky situation but the united states
has an agreement with the chinese
mainland chinese saying that yeah okay
taiwan is part of china but
you you can't take it by force
and that's the excuse they're going to
use to
make sure they uh give weapons to taiwan
and all the necessary uh assistance for
taiwan to defend itself now you're
saying the
taiwan semiconductor which i worked with
by the way i worked with taiwan
yeah i did and uh taiwan semi-conductor
is one of the country one of the
companies that uh supplies
most of the chips in the world i think
it's the number one company right now
you don't want that falling into the
hands of chinese for two reasons one
speak one because they have suddenly you
know control of the faucet they can say
well we we're not gonna sell you any
more chips those chips are coming to
china and then the other one is that
suddenly you know you gain a lot of
knowledge as far as chip manufacturing
because again china's like six seven
years behind the west
and so they would gain a lot with that
but then there's the counter part of
that and that is that before the
taiwanese lose their country to the
chinese they could destroy tsmc taiwan
some argument
or ship it out or throw i mean
burnt land policy burnt land in the
sense of destroying everything and
letting go of the territory
uh
russia did it many times did it with uh
napoleon did it with hitler they just
burned you know
uh slash and burn
wow
don't leave anything behind to the enemy
you think like a spy now before we
conclude uh someone had asked the
question about your life as a spy
perhaps you can give us an idea of uh
maybe a story that you've been uh
so you were a spy for which agencies and
who were you working for
i i don't know anymore
yeah i remember some turn coating if i
if i remember correctly your story
no uh first i approached the cubans okay
and i worked with the cubans for many
years uh what is it 12 years
and uh
through them uh with the soviet union
where the warsaw pact and uh the way it
worked is the cubans never told uh told
the russians the soviets right never
told them who i was
but yeah we had um the head of the
kgb his name was kruczhkov at the time
and uh
met a delegation from the cubans that
went to moscow and delivered tons of
material that i had delivered to the
cubans over many years
and so they gave him all this stuff and
suddenly they say you know this is a big
coup that you have against the americans
that you've got this guy in there but
they didn't know who who it was okay
they never knew the russians never
learned about me
and it turns out that you know uh well
over time i lost my faith in communism
a big mistake in my life what can i say
you know and uh because of that i turned
myself into the cia okay and they
started using me in an operation against
cuba
okay so now they've started using me
against cuba turns out that we worked
for two years with uh fbi and yet but
cia worked with the fbi they were
together in this thing because they all
were there in texas in austin texas i
had the fbi the cia we were like five
people there two from the
cia and three from the fbi and we worked
on um you know providing certain type of
information that would help them
penetrate the
interior ministry of cuba and what
happened was that
you know i was there working with them
for two years meanwhile i worked at
intel corporation i got a job at intel
using them as a reference intel found
out about me what i had done at amd
they confronted me with it said i had to
cooperate with an internal investigation
which was really to get information so
that
amd could put me behind bars for what i
did to amd
and so they eventually they fired me but
before they fired me i was able to take
the pentium which was the number one the
state-of-the-art chip
and took it to south america and began
peddling it to iran into china
wow
countless countless russians may have
experienced the pleasure of nes
emulators playing little games on
pentium 5 years in advance
thanks to bill's gate dedication to
information sharing isn't that beautiful
and you get you get imprisoned for this
this is scandalous
yeah three years i was three years ago
three years ah not so bad but i don't
like the way the system you know turns
against you and
it decides that oh you have these
freedoms and oh sharing is great sharing
is great and then you do it and they put
you in jail that's what they do at the
trucker convoy too
let me just say one thing i i went three
years to prison partly because i had uh
it was like this the here was the
prosecutor and here was me and i had my
hand in the nuts of the fbi and they had
their hand in my nuts and it's who
squeezed first because um they were
going to put my wife in prison that was
the issue and so that's how they had me
and i had a lot of information on the
fbi and the cia the cia was raising
national security issues they were not
going to allow a lot of that information
to get into the court and that would
have gone against the fbi i had agents
filmed with you know and them paying me
and so on so they were in big trouble
with me but they had my wife they were
gonna put my wife in prison so uh even
though there was no law i had to plead
guilty because it was too risky and i've
seen that happen to people inside the
prison how they go after their wives
absolutely bill thank you so much for
coming i have some announcement to make
solo so i'll continue the show it was a
pleasure talking to you again and we'll
do it again very soon
okay bye-bye bye bye all right that was
a pleasurable experience once again
always fun to speak
with bill gate what an amazing man